fresh off of the win against the New
England Patriots the Tennessee Titan
two-time Pro Bowler with Pat McAfee here
on the Rich Eisen show Taylor Luana how
you been Taylor are we live boys we are
live with Pat McAfee sir word on the
street is you guys are talking about
free Catholics I thought I bought in a
little bit if I jump in for a second hey
Pat how you doing bud I'm excellent
Taylor I love everything that has
happened to you from you getting rich to
being a leader of the team devrait will
be coming your coach you live in a good
life and it's fun to watch Taylor hey
guy just say something for a second and
and Rick I'm really I've apologized I'm
gonna switch it over go into max P for a
second I gotta say man one of my buddies
DM me the other day on Instagram throws
me a little Instagram shot and it's
somebody I'm not a little spoiler alert
it's you doing the the beer pong dance
that little little thing yeah and I
gotta say I scroll to the Instagram man
I have become a big fan you got yourself
some humor on you but I don't know what
bug that is but I need it going on
Taylor you got it I watched you then and
it felt top 100 this is fun you see this
this is a to lationship I follow him he
follows me on Twitter it's awesome it's
been so much fun watching you on the NFL
top 100 shows you're hysterical and I
think what you've been doing on the
football field and at the national
Predators games is awesome Taylor I
can't wait to buy a LuAnn Jersey all
right you know what is anything that
this show has done it's bonded a
friendship that sounds like there's
gonna be a little thing on the side that
says best net right next to it
it's Tom at heart and it's gonna be us
this has been awesome I can't wait I
cannot wait for to be best friends with
you Taylor this is really well I'll talk
to you guys next week all right
you know I'm so glad that do you two are
so tight just be careful Pat because you
might one day might turn around he'll
just change his phone number on you and
D follow you on twitter and you have no
way to connect with Mike's Taylor hold
on hold on I did change my phone number
about it and defaul you I'm a huge Rich
Eisen fan excuse me Taylor the lawn
Oh yikes the number of times I've direct
messaged you oh no you're lying fact is
it you you were one of the chris's that
direct messaging then no no no no that's
from the show account I'm talking about
me personally Wow about to Michigan all
my you know what if this is this is not
fake news if this is the real thing
then let me start with a formal
that is not the way I do business
no I told you as far as I'm concerned I
knew there was a top one and now McAfee
Ernest we had top two favorites and and
the to Chris's I don't want them to be
worried they're top ten for circle
clearly just looking at one and two
right now and in an aside he like he
thought it you wouldn't hear it but he
knew you would hear it I'm just gonna
drop and be honest I I would never do it
to rich I don't a figure outside both my
mouth but I have no issue on following
somebody I go through and I filter out
quite a bit of people you separate the
wheat from the chaff like LeBron right
as the season goes along you just start
you start tightening the rotation is
what you do yeah exactly I started
looking I don't talk to you anymore
unfollow and it's heartless man I am
absolutely heartless when it comes to
the unfollow I was pad I was saying
before he came on I'm like it's gotta be
a reporter from the NFL Network says
something you don't like you unfollow
his ass Taylor yeah yeah I'm not a
blocker I'll be honest I think there's a
fine line what is the bombing just
knowing your space and blame disrespect
I'm not a blocker okay Taylor I'm glad
now we could we get that out of the way
how's that Titan season coming along
yeah well now it's time for me to get
politically correct on everybody I'm not
retired like good old Patti can do
whatever he wants that's true I would
say I think you know I think what the
last couple of weeks we've been turning
in the right direction
a couple weeks ago going at the bye week
we were definitely stuff a little fork
in the road and had to make a decision
and we're turning towards making that
right decision and so we're going into a
very hostile environment that you know
that really well and really good fans
out there that if anything no football I
think you can you can hear a pin drop
when the offenses on the field program
is extremely loud when the when the
defense is on the field so that's
because they've been on Angie's plane as
good as ever that's because they've been
punished by Peyton Manning like when
Peyton was there whenever he would put
his arms down to be quiet I honestly
believe there's babies and hospitals
that would stop crying
the entire city would shut up Taylor was
why no doubt I mean hey he's an
authoritative figure about it I've heard
I've heard stories I've definitely heard
stories so now a Taylor let's get really
into it here what so what's next week
gonna be like with your coach Michigan
Ohio State week let's let's just really
zero in on being truly important stuff
okay I'm fully bought into the Michigan
man mentality and I am I am all-in
we're number four I'm looking I'm
looking ahead to the playoffs but I'm
reigning it in for one more game bridge
I'm Bianchi I don't even know who were
playing this week
no it's Indiana Indiana okay well that's
great Hoosiers that that's unbelievable
I love it to death I'm I cannot wait to
play Ohio State I'm gonna I'm gonna pay
his secretary his name stretch he hates
being called a secretary I'm gonna pay
him to just have the Michigan fight song
playing throughout the hallways the
entire Miss Michigan called is wild big
turn creates a lot of cults it's insane
I've never seen anything like them on
Michigan people are all in on me Sean
Ward's Pat strong words for a best
friend to say to another best friend
because again I'm trying not to get
ahead of myself here Taylor I mean this
is a big one you already played the
fight song in practice right didn't you
you snuck that one in there during
training camp if I'm not mistaken I had
him with the fight song and I mean
rebels already got it he's got a very
very short he's very short if he can go
off like that oh and that's Annie when
that fight song started going he started
screaming and yelling and so I think
we'll definitely hit you know butt heads
a little bit next week but I mean
anything and I can all say a la anything
that man would like to bet within reason
under the 250 dollar been one for the
NFLPA of course it's us to course worst
day anything he wants to do if he wants
to wear jerseys and sings fight songs
anything he wants I am willing to deal
with that man I I'm willing to bet it
I'm willing to bet the house I believe
in the blue I'm a couple years ago I
wouldn't have been so on the boat that
sense here this year fair weather as it
gets right now man I am on the train as
you should be che seems to be a really
dominant human of
Harbaugh seems to getting a hold of it
let's talk about for a mo for a second
yo he'll pay you $250 the most you can
gamble in an NFL locker room at any
given time it has ever happened in the
history of NFL lockers you guys could
gamble that what does he like as a coach
because it seems as if he's got the
boxing gloves on in practice after the
games you guys are punching each other
seems like he's just like an OG player
who he has the final say in things but
the locker room respects the hell out of
them am i right there I think I mean you
nailed it I really need to say anything
else he's a he's what we referred to in
the locker room as he's a boy like he
gets it he's for the boys he's got that
he's got that attitude where it can be
if you're if you're a little sensitive
you can take it the wrong way but he
always rallies around with a little
humor on the side to it I got to be
honest the way he's kind of elevated us
all playing he'll call anybody else
it'll be Marcus who wouldn't you know
say anything to anybody or it could be
me who this loudmouth as possible he'll
he'll torture us off if we need it and
so he keeps us humble and we're we're
definitely happy to have him to the
coach all right Taylor well look when
you go to Indianapolis and you look up
in the crowd because everybody's got a
jersey there count up the McAfee numbers
okay yeah they're grossly overpaying for
a jersey that went out of I mean the one
looks good but they they're expensive
jerseys people should not be spending
money on them let me tell you one little
magazine saying I did have the honor I
will say not the honor the displeasure
I'm changing the whole thing the
displeasure of playing against him
before he retired and I think it was
like at half or something like that
you came out once they kick off and you
like boots pooched it up I don't know
how wouldn't kick her words are but you
talk up in the air and you guys end up
recovering it yeah
and the crowds going crazy and I look at
that over at this jackass wearing a
onesie and he has literally got his fake
pitching wedge out taking a swing like
this am i I'm a rookie at the time and
I'm like this guy who is this guy
literally runs out of the tunnel
specialists never never ever ever get an
ounce out of the top two when I got
intro there was quite a little pop I was
surprised I think it went Andrew Luck
venue yes sir the last guy to come out
I'm gonna be honest it was it was
impressive
I've never seen a punter who it's up in
the air if I have souls or not up in the
air I've never seen somebody have so
much so many cheer factor going on
that's really nice yeah it means a lot
to people in Indianapolis for great
humans you know they like my mug shot
okay so this is what needs to happen
Taylor when you get hooked up with Pat
McAfee Pat give me Taylor's new number
okay just in case he doesn't reef all
owe me on Twitter and I am fixing
everything eight plus I need you to go
and you get my phone what happens well
so you just start hiring people to start
following start telling people what to
do man tell you the man thanks for
calling in okay you got it good luck man
Taylor Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience